[Music]
recently we started a new site called
conan dot triple x okay yes it is a real
website all right this is over super
sexy super sec thank you Andy this is
like pretty high octane right and then
this bumps it up so far we debuted three
Conan xxx videos on the site one girl 20
pencils that got a lot of hits please do
the crossword with my wife was this
thing that we and one guy two bowls
starring around Andy Richter eating two
bowls of soup well tonight we've got
another Conan xxx video to show you it's
called lebombo reads from the Victoria's
Secret catalogue out loud
alright thanks for doing this what's
your name la banda
okay la Bamba and what are you gonna be
reading from today Victoria's Secret
catalogue
angels in love alright I'll let you do
you think okay
dream angels Denny now softer than ever
it's the demi of your dreams size is 30
to be 240
[Music]
the Triple D please
[Music]
[Music]
you know what it says on the cue card
now I'm supposed to now say go check it
out at konanov xxx but guess what
don't go check it out I take it back
just don't know I'm not want to promote
it no one should be seeing that it's
horrible put away the card that says
wear it we're to look it up I don't care
get rid of it no one should ever look at
that by the way good work La Bamba
[Applause]